>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Taina Caragol: Hello
good evening all.
My name is Taina Caragol and I'm the
curator of Latino Art and History
at the National Portrait
Gallery and the curator
of One Life Dolores Huerta.
Thank you very much
for being here tonight.
Welcome to poets unite.
A program organized by the National
Portrait Gallery in collaboration
with the Library of Congress
Hispanic Division and Poetry
and Literature Center and with Letra
Latinas, the literary initiative
at the University of Notre Dame's
Institute for Latino Studies.
Tonight we have the honor to have
among us Juan Felipe Herrera,
the 2015 Poet Laureate
of the United States.
Which also we presented
in the Portrait Gallery's
permanent collection by the way,
I don't know if you know that.
Also Arlene Biala,
Poet Laureate of Santa,
the county of Santa
Clara in California.
And award winning poet Diana Garcia
who will read poems in response
to One Life Dolores Huerta.
One Life is not only exhibition,
series of exhibitions really
that shed light on individuals
who through their leadership have
helped shaped American History
and culture.
This iteration based on [inaudible]
Dolores Huerta, a figure essential
to the farm workers
movement of Cesar Chavez.
But not yet as familiar
to the American public.
The mutual identification
of Chavez and Huerta
with migrant farm workers,
their common indignation
other subhuman working
and living conditions,
led to them found
in 1962 the National Farm
Workers Association or NFWA.
In September 1965,
their mainly Mexican
and Mexican-American Union joined
the Filipino Union named the
Agricultural Workers Organizing
Committee led by Larry Itliong
in the momentous Delano Grape Strike
that launched the Farm
Workers Movement.
Both unions merged a year later
and formed the United Farm Workers.
These exhibition commemorates
50 years
of the beginning of these movement.
By illuminating Dolores
Huerta's crucial role in the UFW
as it's Vice President, a
strategist of the Grape's Boycott,
that perhaps some of you remember.
A remarkably skilled
lobbyist for the union
and it's main contact negotiator
between the 60's and 70's.
It is very meaningful for us at
the Portrait Gallery to collaborate
in this program with Chicano poets
Juan Felipe Herrera and Diana Garcia
and Filipino American Arlene
Biala, who shares a commitment
to social justice, cultural
affirmation and given voice
to communities that have been
historically silenced or oppressed.
Juan Felipe and Diana Garcia
come from farm worker families
and were born in farm labor camps.
Their personal stories are
directly tied to Dolores's struggle.
As some of you know this program was
suppose to take place in January,
but it had to be rescheduled
due to the big snow storm.
What a better day to respond to
Dolores Huerta's endless energy
and power as transformational figure
than in International Women's Day.
[ Applause ]
I should also add that I
think the stars aligned
to have the program tonight as well,
because about 50 years ago right
around this time in 1966, in March
of 1966 the, Cesar Chavez started
in the UFW which wasn't the UFW yet,
but the union of these two
labor unions, the Filipino
and Mexican-American union
started their march from Delano
to Sacramento, their 340 mile
march to protest the conditions of,
the working conditions
of farm workers
and to let the state
government to really engage them
in the struggle of farm workers.
On behalf of the Portrait Gallery
I'd like to thank the poets
for the privilege of hearing their
responses to the show tonight.
And I'd also like to give a very
special thanks to Francisco Aragon,
Director of Letra Latinas and also
to Robert Casper and Anya Creightney
as well as Georgette Dorn from
the Library of Congress Poetry
and Literature Center and
also the Hispanic Division.
A big thank you as well to our
two sponsors for this program,
the Smithsonian Latino Center
who also sponsored the
exhibition One Life Dolores Huerta
and the Smithsonian Asian
Pacific American Center.
And thanks again to, as well
to The Portrait Gallery staff
that has worked in the
coordination of this event.
To finish I'd like to remind you
all that One Life Dolores Huerta is
up until May 15, it will
possibly travel starting the fall
of next year through the country.
So if you know venues that would be
interested in receiving this show
as panel exhibition
please let us know.
And I would like also to
let you know that several
of the portrait collections have the
authors presenting tonight will be
available at our shop so please,
when you come see the
exhibition also come
by our shop and support our poets.
And now I give the word to Francisco
Aragon Director of Letra Latinas,
who will tell you more
about this program.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Francisco Aragon: My
name is Francisco Aragon
and I direct Letra Latinas,
which is the literary initiative
at the University of Notre Dame's
institute for Latino Studies.
When it comes to programming,
the core of our philosophy
is collaboration.
Since establishing our presence
in Washington D.C. In 2007,
we've been fortunate enough
to partner with a number
of local institutions and these
have included such institutions
such as The Shakespeare, Folger
Shakespeare Library, Split this Rock
and of course one of our
partners this evening The Library
of Congress, specifically the
Poetry and Literature Center.
The programming Letra
Latinas has carried
out in Washington D.C has been made
possible thanks to the generosity
of the Weissberg Foundation.
I'd like to take a moment
to thank Wally Babington,
a Weissberg board member
who is with us this evening.
I shall also say that along with
the Library of Congress's Poetry
and Literature Center we've also
established a great partnership
with the Hispanic Division.
But tonight we are also partnering
with a branch of the Smithsonian,
the National Portrait
Gallery and this is special
because this is the 3rd time
that Letra Latinas has
partnered with the Smithsonian.
The first was in 2009 when
we co-presented the poetics
of labor series with the National
Museum of American History.
In tandem with its exhibit
Bittersweet Harvest,
The Bracero Program 1942, 1964.
One of the poets who presented
in that series is back
with us this evening, Diana Garcia.
In 2013 we began the collaboration
with the Smithsonian American
Art Museum in conjunction
with the exhibit, Our America, The
Latino Presence in American Art.
One of the outcomes
of that collaboration,
which concludes next
year, is the special issue
of poetry magazine this
month's issue, March,
which includes a portfolio
of 20 poems by 12 poets.
One of those poets is another poet
we'll be hearing from this evening,
US Poet Laureate Juan
Felipe Herrera.
But of course tonight's
collaboration will specifically
engage with as been said,
One Life Dolores Huerta.
And it will yield our
first collaboration
with our third poet this
evening Arlene Biala.
The printed program for tonight's
events, which I hope you all have
in hand, includes biographical
sketches
of our three distinguished poets.
But what I want to
say right now is this,
all three like myself are
natives of California.
From where I recently returned after
taking part in a memorial tribute
to a recently departed
poet and dear friend.
I think Juan Felipe, Diana and
Arlene will agree with me when I say
that the ethos and spirit of our
now departed poet friend is in sync
with the ethos and spirit behind the
exhibit we're celebrating tonight.
So with this in mind, I
want to close these remarks
with a brief poem titled,
Ode to Dolores Huerta
by the late Francisco X Alarcon.
Because you were the
strongest, caring, mother,
protesting against social
injustice in the new war.
Your ribs were broken
many times over.
Your spleen smashed,
split and you were thrown
like any rose to the ground.
Clubbed down on the
street by the SF PD.
But Dolores, you remain a
May carnation on the lips
of our people in prayer
and in praise.
Francisco X Alarcon.
[ Applause ]
And now without further delay
please welcome our poets
who will be presenting in
this order Arlene, Biala,
Diana Garcia and Juan
Felipe Herrera.
[ Applause ]
>> Arlene Biala: Good evening
everybody, how is everybody?
Very very good, [foreign word]
thank you, [foreign word] to Taina
for a beautiful, beautiful exhibit,
if you have not seen the
Dolores Huerta One Life Exhibit,
please go check it out
before it leaves here in May.
And to Francisco, my heart
to you for sharing that poem
from our beloved Francisco
X Alarcon.
I'm going to share a
couple of poems tonight
that were inspired
by the exhibition.
And one of the quotes
from Dolores Huerta is,
when you have nothing left
you still have your body.
And it's around the concept, very
prevalent in Civil Rights activism
and social justice that you use your
body for teach ins, for sit ins,
for protests and that is
what we'll carry forward.
[ Singing ]
What is the song of your body?
Is it [foreign word]
and [foreign word]?
A love song of resistance.
Is it [foreign word]
and [foreign word]?
The chorus of huelga, huelga.
The same word in Spanish
and in Tagalog.
What is the song of your body
standing barely five feet tall?
Yet shifting mountains,
lifting the voices
of thousands of women
who say enough.
It is time to rise.
What is the song of your fingers?
That grip the megaphone.
Base notes mean business.
Don't be a marshmallow.
Get off the sidewalk,
get into the streets.
Out, out from the mud.
Out, out from the pesticides,
out from the weight
of your broken bodies.
What is this song of your hands?
That write the contract
for the first time.
That wiped the blood from your face.
What is this song of
your hands on your hips?
Ready to hear the excuses that
crop up as they always do.
But you are here.
This poem, actually is a series
of poetry form called Haynaku
and it's a play off of
the short form Haiku.
Which is, most of you might be
familiar with, raise your hand
if you know what a Haiku is?
Right, so 575 syllable count tercet.
This is also a tercet
so three lines,
but the form is basically one word,
two words and then three words
and it can be reversed as well.
An I Knuckle is a form that
was originated and founded
by my beautiful friend,
Filipino poet Eileen Tabios
and Haynaku means the translation
is sort of like, [foreign word]
or oh my god, you know
you're just sort
of like, what in the world right?
So I would like for you,
if you would indulge me,
to help me with this
poem, with this chant.
And when I raise my hand like this,
if you would yell out huelga, okay.
Going to need everybody with me.
Okay. First one, huelga.
Dragon lady they call you.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: All
men except for you.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Same
word Tagalog and Spanish.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Red
vest, your body rising.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: You
demand, commit your body.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Blood
grapes strike the heart.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Baton
smash ruptured your spleen.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: 11
children find a way.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: The
Filipinas are tired too.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Laureate
[foreign word], we are here.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Exhausted
women lead the march.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Hunger
striking, that is love
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: See
her, red mother rising.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Beyond
this, she is here.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Same
age as my mother.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: No back
seat, do not buckle.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Hospital
bed, Cesar is there.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Same
word, we are you.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: My
sister, take this water.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Our
sister, take this breath.
>> Huelga.
>> Arlene Biala: Thank you, huelga.
[ Applause ]
>> Diana Garcia: The first poem is
called Delta Angel and it's taken
from an uncredited photograph
called, Dolores Huerta
as a majorette, it's part
of the family holdings.
I never knew.
Main street angel, glitter
in your majorette costume,
each sequin hand sown.
Strut for the camera, your
baton waves, arcs, ready to fly.
Passers by stop, admire
your exuberance.
Spine straight taller than
your friend beside you,
taller than you thought
you would be.
All eyes follow your form,
slim waist, high breasts,
grace and strength in
each toss of the baton.
This is you, tasseled cape hat,
set to lead the band every parade,
every Friday night, every
Friday night halftime,
every band competition.
Who taught you intricacies
of baton work?
Who taught you confidence?
The feel of hard steel in
both hands, working the baton
from one hand to the other, over,
under, above, through, between?
Sometimes the clunk on the head?
How many bruises suffered for
this one moment each week?
Delta Angel leading the way,
charging headlong beneath
the late autumn sun.
In the heat, delta water
flushes your heart and lungs.
Delta soil lifts each time
your boots hit their mark.
On Friday nights your baton
arcs beneath the lights,
a 100 yard stage just for you.
Lights bounce of baton, sequins.
Lights swirl like stars against
your dark skin and skirt.
You hear the delta call of
sand hill cranes settling,
snowy egrets flying overhead.
You pull for the star,
strain against gravity.
Your baton strings in
the fog, wings shimmer.
This next poem Huelga, after Harvey
Richards 1965 photograph Huelga.
September 24th, 1965
Delano California.
You remember this day.
How can you forget?
Iconic this photo, outsize
reproduction guiding us in.
The great strikes in Delano, where
it all began and you were there.
Look at you atop a truck,
sun in your eyes, you squint.
Sensible clothes, sleeves pushed
up passed your elbows,
your get to work look.
Comfy dark slacks, nothing
you'd wear to church,
nothing you'd wear turning trays.
You turned from side to side,
arms tired from holding the sign.
It looks heavy, the
word huelga feels heavy.
Think of what this word means to all
those who follow you out that day.
Think of the lives
changed by this one word,
workers daring to claim their lives.
Daring to think their arms, backs,
legs should earn them
more than substance wages.
More than a quick meal midday, more
than those furtive trips to the edge
of the fields, hunkered
down against crying eyes.
More than dry eyes
and dryer throats.
The heat rises, pushes
against your face,
singles you out atop that truck.
You must wonder if even now someone
has you in their cross hairs.
You must wonder what would
happen to your children.
But you can't think about them,
because this is about your children.
If this is about all the children,
about all these young workers,
ready to walk out,
ready to follow you,
ready not to grow old
beneath another hot sun.
A 300 Mile March.
NFW flags bluster and blow.
The value winds blow
from the east, new day,
new beginnings, a few dozen workers.
They hoist the flags,
take their first steps.
A 300 mile march.
Audacious, Filipino and
Mexican field workers daring
to cast their struggles
across the length and breath
of California's great
Central Valley.
So few, you'd hoped for dozens more.
But the media trucks soon
bloom, photographers,
newspapers cover the story.
The story grows and
so do the numbers.
What do hundreds of
boots and sandals sound
like as they pound asphalt up
Highway 99 and all its tributaries?
The storm of passion,
tectonic surge, the rumble
and roar beneath the feet, the
earthquake and hurricane in Shirako
and what else can we call it?
The mad howl of parents,
parents telling children
there is not enough food,
not enough for new clothes,
warm jackets, clothes that fit,
not enough for the doctor when
one child struggles to breath,
not enough air, not
enough money, never enough
and now huelga they scream,
[foreign word] they roar
and if that's not enough [foreign
word] enough, they have had enough.
[ Applause ]
The next Dragon Lady is taken from
a uncredited photograph of Huerta
at the Gala Negotiations in 1973.
Remind you of something?
Men in charge.
Usually men, usually
white men in white shirts
and perfectly knotted ties.
Good ole boys taught
to tie a tie in front
of a bathroom mirror at age 12.
But here in this simmering heat,
they've shed the ties, the suits
and jackets, hunkered down,
ready to take you down.
Even as you prepare to break the
wall they've built word by word,
line by line, point by point.
In your checked jacket
and white blouse,
they should remember the
images of wives at church.
Small armies of women
wielding power,
ancestral lines of
women behind them.
They should recall who wields the
final word in any disagreement.
What do they call women
like you behind their back?
Don't think about it.
Your hand moves across one
of several pages, strewn
across the table.
The man to your right follows
each movement, each cross out,
cringes as your pen hovers
over one critical section.
See him flinch as you
grasp its importance.
When Cesar handed you this
responsibility you crammed
for one week, reviewing
all you'd learned
about contract negotiations
in the past years.
First the dates and [inaudible],
now wine and raising grapes.
You must have felt like you were
back in college cramming for finals.
You did now what you did then.
When you got to the hall,
you walked through the doors
as if you were leading a
field full of strikers.
You claimed the best seat,
but looked aside not
straight at them, not yet.
You gave them a chance to grasp, you
were the lead negotiator, not Cesar,
not a man trained in law school, but
you with your state college degree,
you mother of half a dozen children,
you mother to this movement.
Dragon Lady, that's what they'll
call you at the end of this day.
Dragon lady howling heat and dust
on this contract, summoning decades
of sweat and blisters and bent
backs, twirling lassos of words,
specific words, demanding words,
gorging on the power
of words to dismantle.
[ Applause ]
And finally, Different Ways to Heal.
And this is from a photograph from
Victor Alaman of Chavez sitting
with Dolores Huerta in the
hospital after she'd been beaten
and her spleen ruptured and ribs
broken by San Francisco's police.
You watch.
You sit and watch.
Hour after hour.
What else can you do?
You can't heal her,
no one can do that.
You can't take away the
nightmare, the feel of metal baton
on shoulder, hip, kidney.
You can't remove the sound,
the memory of flesh crumbling
beneath the weight and power
of San Francisco's finest.
You wait. Not like waiting those
long months before you sign the
first contract.
Your eyes stray to her,
stay away from her.
This woman who's stood by
your side, who worked with you
to found this union, this woman
who agreed the monotonous way
of non-violence, augured well for
the stance you all would take,
in the face of hate filled faces,
fists that slowed your chance,
your songs, your flying
flag into oblivion.
You turn away from the photographer,
your face obscured
by your left hand.
Do you regret not being at her
side when the police attacked?
Are you racked with guilt?
Aware of what your [foreign
word] will say, those back home
who expect a man to take
the blows, not the woman.
You wait because there is
nothing else you can do.
You wait, because surgery only
heals the body but what of the soul?
Bound to a hospital bed draped
in white, propped up on pillows,
she stares straight
ahead, not at you.
No smile, no attempt
at conversation.
The dragon lady holds herself close.
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's beautiful.
I'm so honored to be here
with Diana and Arlene.
To listen to their amazing poems.
To feel and to see those moments
once again, presented in many ways
at Taina's gallery, room project
Dolores Huerta One Life and to be
in the midst of women
leaders right here.
It's a wave of creativity,
it's a wave of being brave,
of being pioneers and
this is what I mentioned
to [inaudible] just
a few minutes ago
and for me it's a beautiful honor
and I can feel Dolores Huerta here.
So let's give a [foreign word],
leaders right here a big
[foreign word], a big hand.
[ Applause ]
And [applause] that's right.
That is right.
Also to, once again give thanks to
the Library of Congress's Department
of Literature Rob Casper and the
Portrait Center and Letra Latinas,
Notre Dame Institute with
Francisco Aragon and all those
that are part of this project.
I feel really good about it because
it's once again as we can see,
as you can see, it's bringing
into our minds, into our presence,
right here in Washington D.C.,
this amazing gallery, the face
and the life of Dolores Huerta.
A most brave and most keen mind and
leader and activist on the ground,
on the earth for so many.
And it's so easy for our
leaders in particular,
women to be slowly erased
or evaporated by the media
and of course by the onslaught,
the continuous corporate
onslaught of things to purchase.
And all those other good things.
Let me read you a poem.
Jose Montoya, Jose Montoya who
also passed away not to long ago.
A great poet, muralist,
painter who early on was part
of the campesino movement with
Cesar Chavez and Dolores Huerta.
And the farm workers, he was also
a farm worker for [foreign word]
in Northern Mexico, in New Mexico
and he painted these stories.
On amazing murals throughout
California and the Southwest
with his artists, so Sacramento,
many artists from Sacramento,
the real Chicano Air Force.
And gave you know a large
public face and history
through the visual
images and documents
from an artists point of view.
So he dedicated his life to this.
So, he passed away in 2013
and I thought I'd bring
him into view tonight.
Since he was a great participant
with Dolores Huerta
and Cesar Chavez.
So this is a node to Jose
Montoya and I have it in Spanish
and [foreign word] Spanish, the
kind of Spanish you know you speak,
we speak kind of in
between everything.
You know on the border lands,
on the border and as we grow up
and before we take Spanish
one like I did [laughter].
And Spanish two and three and four.
And ideally you make it to
Spanish five [laughter].
Ode to Jose Montoya,
[foreign word] Jose Montoya.
So how we're going to do it now?
With your [foreign word]
portfolio[foreign word]
about [foreign word] bad
goose from second war El Paso.
And the [foreign word] with hard
work, head bands and revolution
and that rap on the three streets.
Braided. Border [foreign
word] boulevard.
And now you come out of the
bottom of VW van [foreign word],
painted murals, solar blastoff,
incense, [foreign word] is sacred.
The blessing of [foreign word].
The tiny earth, red, color
of chile from hatch, roasted.
20 kilos and [foreign
word] gunnysack.
And your art fire on
adolescent foreheads.
And the hearts of generations
will say your kindness,
your voice dubby dubby doo
wop [assumed spelling].
Give me the flying coat color of
flaming tooty fruity, paint me.
The face, color lying
by you and color
of Cesar Chavez, Dolores
Huerta flag.
Do not forget the how.
You hear it?
Do you hear it all the way from
Logan Heights Bayou to Sacra.
Jazz of the 40's across I5 and
99, [foreign word] Jose Montoya.
Forever. A sweet forever.
My brother.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Multiple Speakers ]
Diana by the way.
Diana and Arlene structured this
choreographic [foreign word].
Just give them [inaudible]
right before it begins.
[ Laughter ]
>> Diana Garcia: Maybe better they
should clap afterwards if it works.
>> Arlene Biala: You hear the
laughing coming from the back,
backstage it's because we forgot
to turn off our microphones
while we were doing this.
>> Diana Garcia: Hopefully
you couldn't hear things.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: And
I told Diana and Arlene,
you know we're just going
to flow okay you know,
let's just let it flow.
And then I went back into the, into
the green room, [foreign word] room.
[ Laughter ]
And Diana was busy and Arlene
was busy putting it all together.
>> Diana Garcia: Slow nothing.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
[foreign word] was seven tongues,
[foreign words] said, back in
time, [foreign words] Mexico said,
you seven tongues talk so fast, wind
and lightning, last time I saw you,
behind Bakersfield,
must have been 2012,
high school scholarship fundraiser
we pronounced you Poet Laureate
of Kings County.
If no one else does it, no
one else does it, we'll do it,
[foreign words], bottom line still
in 2016 more food,
more clean water, more.
>> Diana Garcia: Walk the
street with us into history,
get off the sidewalk, work for
justice, Aztec eagle, dragon lady,
twirl talents, feathers,
cape of sharp and pointed,
swirled blast of breath,
furnace roar.
>> Arlene Biala: We are
all saying the same thing.
Spanish, English, Tagalog some who
can read it, others who will teach.
I'm thinking about what is
missing and you were calling us in.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
More dollars gets a school,
after all these years more
food, more peace, more marches,
that is what you taught us.
Use the feet, use the hands,
[foreign word], [foreign word],
each step kisses the earth scarred,
bummed, burned, preemptive, boom,
bust, forsaken, bloodied, they're
the workers that heal it, eagle.
>> Diana Garcia: Funnel clouds,
funnel forests, [foreign words],
create, create a movement, use
your feet, your hands, your brains,
your mouth, power through
wind and lightning,
thunder roars from
talons, lightning springs.
>> Arlene Biala: You are the only
woman in the room at the table.
Legal pad pages poised
and ready to strike.
Two men sitting to your
side are joking around,
wondering when lunchtime is and
what you will be asked to bring.
Rows of men sitting behind you,
some slumped in their chairs.
Before they leave, they've left.
>> Diana Garcia: Next.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Eagle dragon, eagle people,
pilgrimage clan walking nowhere.
Too change for the good,
for the excerpt, for all.
>> Diana Garcia: Scorched
fields, no marshmallows here,
marshmallows roast in
summer heat, valley weather,
tie the vines, turn the trays.
>> Arlene Biala: We are
all saying the same thing.
The difference is your red knit
vest, small enough to be a child's.
With the black eagle soaring
across the room toward us.
The first thing I notice
your ribcage swelling.
Heart almost bursting through,
held back only by the weaving
of [foreign word], chanted into
each click of knitting needles,
that were offered up to protect you.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: At
the foot of the fountain,
some cannot see it,
some cannot read.
>> Diana Garcia: Walk out of the
fields, walk out, walk into history,
see your children glide university
halls, this is what we do, we lead,
we lead, we march into history.
>> Arlene Biala: Your fierce small
body relentless beyond miles,
beyond broken ribs.
You call us to that
eagle that soars,
proclaiming in every language,
here is what America is.
We are what America is.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Siete, seven.
One, compassion.
Two, struggle, [foreign word].
Three, debate, analysis.
Four, fast, fast for
30 days, just water.
Five, call the people.
Six, knock on every door.
Seven, lifetime.
One, your, yours, for
all, lifetimes.
Knit, vest, with each name of the
invisible lives, the threat of path,
a pilgrimage with the [foreign
word] of [foreign word].
>> Diana Garcia: Walk
with us into history.
Fly with us into better lives, more
food, clean water, new shoes dammit,
nothing from [foreign word].
>> Arlene Biala: [foreign word],
rise, huelga, beyond what is present
in the hallway, come
enter the heart cave,
rise we are all saying
the same thing.
Enter the room, enter the room.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Eagle
that soars beyond broken ribs,
within broken ribs you,
we, Filipina, Chicana,
Mexican why are we student mothers.
You who step with peace,
for all broken rib, healers.
>> Diana Garcia: Rise with us where
eagle leads dragon, sheer magnitude,
shear [foreign word], claim
your power, magnificent energy,
all forward, onward,
cause [foreign words].
>> Juan Felipe Garcia: Get off the
sidewalk, walk, find your life,
our life, my mother
Lucha, my father Felipe.
Finding yourself walking 1947 Arlene
and Diana, [foreign word] D.C 2016.
Knit, vest, white, red, blackness,
green, light, flame, still screen,
[foreign word], [foreign
word], on the wall.
Who played with dirt?
Parents, picked, [foreign word].
>> Diana Garcia: Eagle
dragon what kind of clan,
what kind of movement screams,
huelga, huelga, huelga?
Moves with us, walks the streets
with us, out of the fields,
walks with us, marches a march,
get marching, use your lives,
dragon lady roars, use your lives,
make the world a better
place, better always better.
>> Juan Felipe Garcia: The
world becomes as you move it.
How do you move it Dolores?
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> Georgette Dorn: That
was really wonderful,
wonderful congratulations
all of you.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Thank you.
>> Georgette Dorn: I'm going
to ask you a few questions.
Can you talk about your process
both writing, your poems in response
to exhibit, One Life Dolores Huerta?
In working in collaboration?
>> Diana Garcia: I think for me it
was having met her when I was young,
when I was still 18, 19 years old.
And having the, having the great
good fortune to have Louis Valdez
and [foreign word] come
onto campus at Fresno State
and say come with us
into the fields.
And I think that that and then
combined with Taina Caragol
and all the wonderful work
she did on the exhibit
and then Francisco Aragon texting
and saying you do you
want to do this?
And I thought, well hell my
life finally came full circle,
it's about time.
It was, it was a perfect opportunity
to study these photographs
and to have a chance to put
passion in motion, history
and memory along side
the photographs
and then write these poems.
>> Georgette Dorn: Wonderful.
You have any comments?
>> Arlene Biala: I
do, I think echoing
when Diana was saying the work as
you enter this room is so powerful.
And for me the very first
thing that my eye went
to was Dolores Huerta's
vest that was gifted to her.
I think we all brought
that into the poems
when we were writing about the work.
It's just a very small tiny vest
and it's in a shadow box frame
and I looked at it and I thought,
man that things going to bust out.
Right because you immediately
make the connection
with the woman and
the power she held.
And when Felipe and Francisco
had called and asked if I would
like to participate in this first
of all I was completely
floored and humbled and honored.
It was also around the time that
there was a very important movie
by a Filipino producer, Melissa
Aroy, Marissa Aroy excuse me,
that was screening in San Jose and
it's called the Delano Manongs.
And it talks about the
Filipino's history in the movement
and sheds light into the fact that
you know the different cultures
of Filipino's and the
Mexican's were very much,
even though there was
some warring and struggle,
were very much together in
wanting the same things.
So, that vest and all the other
works that are in that room,
very much called forth a
lot of hope and inspiration.
>> Georgette Dorn: Do you have
anything to add Juan Felipe?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Well
you know, yes [laughter].
But it's really all been
sad to tell you truth.
You know humbly, I'm really really
happy again you know that this,
that Taina put this project
together on Dolores Huerta,
here at The National Portrait
Gallery and the Department
of Literature, Rob Casper and
Anya and Matthew are part of this
and sponsored it as
well as everyone else.
You know I've been, it's
been a concern of mine to,
to have such pioneers as
Dolores Huerta as much
as possible in the public's eye.
You know how much media we
get every three seconds.
You know there's pharmaceutical
ads, there's everything
in the whole wide world that's
cost billions, billions literally
after a while of dollars,
that we receive in the media.
We never really receive ten
seconds of Dolores Huerta
for example, in the media.
I don't think I seen Dolores
Huerta in the media at all.
And the entire farm workers
movement and still Cesar Chavez.
And in addition we do not receive
the Filipino, Filipinas story.
So I feel that this
project brings such amazing
and important significant faces for
us to see once again and courage
for use to feel once again.
Incredible courage and a
movement for us to get in touch
with once again that
changed our lives.
And still is changing
our lives and it's part
of all the production
that we benefit from.
In every hamburger there's lettuce
and tomato and pickle and jalapeno.
And I say like that because I'm
joking with you but it's true.
So that's why I feel
this is so important
and of course it touches back
to my own story and our stories.
My parents and how hard they
worked back in those early years
when there was no union and
at a later age in their life
and my father kept on working
until he was 70 in those fields.
So it's like that, it's
such a beautiful to be here.
>> Georgette Dorn: It is yes.
And, in general what
fantastic poetry contributed
to such an exhibit?
>> Diana Garcia: Images.
Images coming from the San Marquis
Valley and knowing Stockton as well
as I do, because so many
family members live there.
To know that she came
out of Stockton and ran
through the entire Central
Valley, for me it was the sounds,
the scents, the feel of the fog in
the winter and heat in the summer.
For me it was, it just drenched with
sensory detail and then the shouts.
The shouts for justice
and the sites.
The huge red banners with
that screaming eagle on it.
It was all imagery.
>> Georgette Dorn: And how do
you connect to Dolores Huerta?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Well you
know I met her in, not to long ago.
And just recently, in her
early 80's, early 80's
and this was in Bakersfield.
And I was invited to say something
as a California Poet Laureate
to a high school fundraiser
audience.
It was maybe around 50
people in Bakersfield
at Cal State University,
Bakersfield.
And this particular group has been
raising funds, having speakers come,
raise funds for the next generation
of students that are continue.
And not much money was raised
but a beautiful effort was made.
And Dolores Huerta was there.
So I got to say hi and thank you.
And I noticed how she's a
solar beam, she's a solar beam.
She just emanates all
this beautiful, strong,
bright, brilliant energy.
And we talked a little bit.
And she said well you know
what, I wanted to be a poet.
She said I wanted to be
a poet in third grade,
but my teacher said I
didn't have any talent.
So then she decided on something
else, which you guys know about.
But it was a very tender
moment for her.
I noticed this, this feeling she
was feeling about being taken,
ripped away from this
poetry she wanted to,
this poetry life she wanted to have.
It was she had it, cause she
was called [foreign word],
seven tongues by her grandfather.
Which we know how she used that too.
So I said you know what
Dolores we're going to take care
of that right now, we're going
to take care of that right now.
So just hold on right now okay.
I said okay everybody, as of today,
we're announcing by the power vested
in me, Kings County Poet Laureate,
cause that's the county you know
for, that Bakersfield was in.
Kings County Poet Laureate and
everybody goes yeah [laughter].
So she's beautiful human being and
the most and I was so fortunate
to have met her at that time.
>> Georgette Dorn: I saw her
last year at the Mexican Embassy
when she got the Aguila Azteca
Prize and she looked marvelous,
she is just amazing,
an amazing person.
What about you?
How do you connect
to Dolores Huerta?
>> Arlene Biala: Dolores Huerta, I
didn't get to ever speak with her,
but I did get to see her, she
came to the Mexican Heritage Plaza
which is now the School of
Arts and Culture in San Jose,
which is the safe way site of the
original Cesar Chavez boycott.
In San Jose she came on a day
when we had I think 3,000 5th
and 6th graders there from
the neighborhood schools.
Huge, huge you know we have
the Cesar Chavez on March 31st
in San Jose and so she was there,
spreading her power and joy
to these 5th and 6th graders that
covered, you know I don't how many,
how many square feet but
it was just a packed plaza.
But the thing that I really connect
with her is that she's the same age
as my mother, my mother's,
she probably has half her
foot of height on my mother.
But man what a powerhouse.
Right, this is you know going
back to thinking about the body
and what it can contain and what
it can barely contain when it comes
to life and that soul, that
fierceness, that was needed
to do the work that she did.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yeah.
>> Arlene Biala: You know.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
>> Georgette Dorn: It's
amazing, thank you.
And the United Farm
Workers, did she ever talk
about the United Farm Workers?
>> Diana Garcia: My own
parents left the fields
when I was seven years old.
When I was two but finally and
completely by the time I was seven.
So my early life was living in Camp
CPC, California Packing Corporation.
What I remember is those very
early mornings in the fields.
Sitting on my fathers gunnysack
while he dragged me along.
Because I couldn't do
my share of picking
or I wouldn't one or the other.
And when they started this movement,
I remember my mom and I sitting
around in the living room talking
about a union for farm workers
and by this time I
was 15, 16 years old.
And it seemed like such
an inconceivable project.
It's like, but the
biggie I should say is,
that even then Dolores
Huerta was well known
in the Central San Marquis Valley
and for my mother this is
a woman who's only a couple
of years older than she is.
For my mother, this woman who
was leaving her family behind
and walking out into the fields
and pulling the workers out,
was so removed from anything
she would ever have imagined
for herself.
And I think that not
only did Dolores Huerta
and the United Farm Workers inspire
us, those of us who were teenagers
and young adults, but they
inspired women of my mothers age
who eventually in her
40's went back to college.
And so I say that, you say that's
a union and a farm workers union
but we say that it was
a peoples movement.
And it was more than
just United Farm Workers.
It grew us up.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
>> Georgette Dorn: You
want to add to that?
>> Arlene Biala: No, I think.
>> Georgette Dorn: Juan Felipe?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right you know.
That's right, you know Diana
says it, you know says it well.
You know we als,o it's good to
acknowledge the community organizers
that kind of shared their methods
with Dolores and Cesar Chavez,
is it Fred Ross, a Jewish
community organizer.
That's also part of the movement
and as Arlene and Diana have said,
all this is kind of part
of our lives you know.
This is what we've been writing
about and talking about and reading
about and kind of keeping
the fires going
with this particular movement I
kind of came into my own poetry
at that particular time,
the late 60's at UCLA.
And I was testing the free speech
mount, I was really testing myself
to see that I could get up
there and read out and speak
out because I was always, it
kind of became my life project,
I don't know what got into me.
But I noticed that I had a hard
time speaking up in 7th grade
and people would ask me what am
I and I would say I'm Hawaiian.
I wish I was you know, I wish I was.
You know cause I had come in
from the Bay Area and I had gone
to school in the Mission District.
So my friends were
Filipino's you know
and Filipinas at school you know.
Honolulu, [inaudible] would
always run ahead of me,
I was trying to catch up to it.
You was so fast and so
tall and Tyronne Akino
and [inaudible] Bautista.
So when I came to San Diego
to go to middle school,
my music teacher said well you know
what are you anyway, I go what?
I don't know I'm, I wish
would Mexican but you know.
I'm Hawaiian, I'm Hawaiian.
And it's ridiculous you know but
I was so afraid to really speak
up and to tell the truth.
So I took choir and I
started putting myself
in impossible situations so I could
you know kick it out of my body,
force out of my body to
speak up and to be true.
So, the farm workers movement
kind of made that happen for me.
And that's why I started
really writing and reciting
and open fields, open eyes
[ Inaudible Question ]
What's that?
That's good, I'd be delighted.
Truly honored, truly honored.
>> Georgette Dorn: Did the
exhibition deepen your understanding
of Dolores Huerta, this
exhibit here in the gallery?
>> Arlene Biala: It did.
I didn't have the personal
history of you know family working
in the fields and as Diana's family
and Juan Felipe's family did,
I mean I had uncles and aunts
who were definitely, in our,
in [inaudible] Valley we were
surrounded by the onion fields
and that's where they
went to do their work.
Cousins in Hawaii actually
who were on the plantations,
in the cane fields, you know
up until very recently
when they closed down.
>> Diana Garcia: Closed down.
>> Arlene Biala: My, so this
exhibition really you know things,
I didn't know she had 11 children.
And was doing all this
work and that alone to me,
you know I have three
children and I'm like woo.
>> Georgette Dorn: Amazing.
>> Arlene Biala: Okay I can't
complain about being tired.
Just again back to that
core strength that she has.
You know and I didn't know
that her life as a young child,
you know she was actually middle
class and was not herself working
in the fields but when
she went to teach,
her young students were coming
to school with no shoes,
she knew that hadn't eaten
because they didn't have any food
and that was the point where
she said, how can I sit here
as a teacher and try to
teach you know writing,
reading, art what have you.
When these children don't
have their basics met.
And so it's at that core of
her passion and her commitment
to making sure that
there's justice you know.
And that's really the core,
how I feel about your
working and your writing.
Which is that, if we don't have that
part within us to generate work,
whether it's [inaudible] you
know work based on works of art
or inspired by dance or theater.
Or a way to express
anger at you know,
[foreign word] whatever
all this ridiculous things
that are happening in the media.
That you wish this was a
bad joke but you realize,
I'm awake, what's going on right?
So, to really remember to
engage and be well with yourself
so that you can share
that positive energy out.
You know and it's women like
Dolores Huerta and people who,
who are consistent in that
bringing forth the core.
That I try to engage with all the
time because the rest is just going
to make you fall down
and cry, right.
>> Georgette Dorn: It's wonderful
to have the exhibition here
for a new generation
to see this marvelous,
amazing woman, isn't that true?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: That's true,
you know there's new generations
and so that's what's also
beautiful about this project.
As we have, we have ourselves
and then we have our new selves
in our new generations that
are learning about this
and it's a beautiful thing to have.
Here on site and Dolores Huerta
at the center and Arlene and Diana
as well and yourself
and everyone here.
>> Georgette Dorn: What does it
mean that the federal institutions
such as the Smithsonian
and the Library
of Congress are celebrating
Dolores Huerta?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: The
walls have come down you know,
the walls have come down.
And there's mighty
bridges being built.
And that's what's amazing.
You know that we're uniting
and doing the good work
of course there's a lot of good
work already at the Library
of Congress and at the Gallery.
And yet this is a new, a new
leaf in that, a new direction
or a continued direction
in that field,
so I think it's most inspiring
especially at a time like this.
>> Georgette Dorn: That's right
and a time like this is true.
>> Diana Garcia: And I
never imagined a moment
like this would come.
>> Georgette Dorn: And I have
one more question and what might
that fact say about the
message of her work?
Which you are promoting
through poetry.
>> Diana Garcia: That
poetry is for everybody.
>> Arlene Biala: Yes absolutely.
[ Applause ]
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Poetry you know,
is what she was doing all along,
she was doing all along poetry
for the people with her voice.
And Arlene and Diana and yourself
and everybody here one more time.
[ Applause ]
>> Georgette Dorn: Thank
you very much, wonderful.
>> Taina Caragol: Thank you
very much Georgette we would
like to open the floor to questions.
The microphones are on both
sides of the auditorium.
>> Thank you so much for
this evenings program.
Not only is this exhibit the first
time that a Latino has been honored
by the Smithsonian in this
way, but I believe you know,
it's the first time that a living
person has been given this honor
or one of the first ones.
What does it mean to have this
project and her life presented
in this way, that history presented
while the person is still living?
And I'm curious as
people who created poetry
around the project
and around her life?
Can you say something about what
it means, the responsibility
of the poet to sort of honor someone
who's living at the same time?
>> Diana Garcia: I teach my students
to write the truth and I feel
like there has been no truth
written about Dolores Huerta
that has had a bigger hearing
than the presentation we're doing
tonight, that the exhibit is one
that blasts apart a silence that
has kept her in second place
and with no one recognizing
that she was the co-founder
of the United Farm Workers.
I'm so, I'm so amazed that a
moment like this can happen
to honor her when she
is still alive.
That it's so tiring
to hear the accolades
after amazing people
like this are dead.
>> Georgette Dorn: Very good,
very good any other questions?
>> Thank you very much to all
of you who are putting this on.
Especially the poets here
tonight and the [inaudible]
for hosting this discussion
all of you are putting on.
I had actually your question
in mind, but then when,
Juan Felipe when you
mentioned the anecdote
about Dolores saying she wished that
her poet when she was just three.
Made me actually think about, for
example your saying new generation
about President Kennedy, who
if most of us who are familiar
with his life story,
have it be almost
to intimately involved cause I
was named John, partly after him.
I just know about his life story,
just remotely I read through it
that as a young man him being rather
sickly and having dealing with a lot
of illnesses, he actually read a
lot, the joke in his family was
that a mosquito bit him,
the mosquito might die actually
all the illness John had.
And anybody familiar with
the Kennedy story knows
that Josey was the first one
actually in line for the presidency.
But then fate intervened and
then John was next in line.
My comment is simply like
rather you having heard
that comment [inaudible]
poets in general.
What do you think it means the
fact that sometimes that her,
that teacher said a comment or
that President Kennedy himself,
as being as a context the
idea of like, he had inspired
to be a teacher and a writer
himself and maybe even a poet
but it didn't quite
work out that way.
Was Dolores, that teacher
said that comment and
yet as you said her life
expresses itself in different ways
through poetry of her activity.
So that was more as a commentary but
rather maybe can reflect on that,
what do you think it all means in
a way lead to a next generation
of those who are told
not to do one thing,
maybe going through your
own forged path we can.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
You know you can ask the,
you can ask up the spirit.
You know she definitely found a way
and her poetry was a bigger poetry.
It wasn't on a page, it didn't
require ink, it was her voice
and her actions and this
great solar power that she has
of facing impossible odds
and making it through.
And bringing about this beautiful
change that we have experienced,
inspiration, changing labor laws,
inspiring millions
and new generations.
So her poem was a mighty big poem.
And she made it through, yes.
>> Taina Caragol: Any
other questions?
>> Diana Garcia: Yeah right here.
>> Okay, yeah first of all I
just really want to thank Taina
for putting this on,
just blows me away.
Yeah I just, so you
hear a lot of this
when we're you know
celebrating Dolores Huerta's life
and I know she's still alive.
But, we hear like get off the
sidewalk, you know and this calls
to action and well first of
all actually Juan Felipe I want
to commend you for taking the
Poet Laureate's position in doing
like really activists
type stuff with it
and like really doing these big
projects that unite people you know,
I think that's really beautiful.
But my main question is, what what
you say to the next generation
and you know here we are like
we're growing, you know we're here.
And I just, I want
to hear some words
from you guys for the
next generation.
>> Arlene Biala: The next
generation is here for sure.
I, what I tell my kids who, who I
think have very very great heart,
passionate hearts sharing
empathy but really have their own,
their own desires of what they
want to do, you know I may say
to my 15 year old, you're
practicing your drums today,
you're practicing your drums today,
you're practicing your drums today
he's like no man I'm going to skate
and I'm going to go play my ukelele.
We can't hold any of you back and
I think people like Juan Felipe
as US Poet Laureate, first US Latino
Poet Laureate, Dolores Huerta here
and the Smithsonian you
know these things are huge
and I think it really
creates as Juan Felipe said,
bringing down walls and just
letting people know to stand up,
to be heard, create your
art, share your passion
for the things that matter.
You know, hey I'm on social media
all the time, I'm guilty of Facebook
and Instagram and all that but
move beyond that, you know remember
to connect with each other.
In very meaningful ways.
And not get lost you know the
whole get off the sidewalk,
don't get lost you
know you could maybe,
yes you can forward you
know petition or something.
But what does that really mean?
How is that helping you grow
and help you know each
one teach one right?
Educate the next and help them
feel strong to rise with you,
with your whole generation.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's right.
>> Arlene Biala: Just do it.
>> If I could also ask a question,
thank you so much for tonight.
I wanted to know if you've noticed
with Huerta and Chavez's life,
if they found encouragement
and influence
from 20th century religious figures
like Oscar Romero, Dorothy Day,
Gustavo Gutierrez, Martin
Luther King, Mother Theresa.
If you noticed them
finding influence
and encouragement from
figures like those?
>> Diana Garcia: Well most
definitely you didn't mention him
from Gandhi.
That was the core to their
own non-violent approach
to union organizing, to
striking, to picketing.
That this would be a
non-violent movement.
The power of non-violence to
speak so much strong, stronger,
so much more loudly
than hitting back.
>> Yeah thank you.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: There was
so many, that's why just a question
of religion is so big isn't it?
It's so big, like [foreign word] and
the [foreign word], the big banner
that kind of led the
pilgrimage of [foreign word]
and beyond that and within that.
You know there were also a
lot of songs, a lot of poetry,
a lot of theater, a lot of story
telling and the famous newspaper
in [foreign word], the
Misbehave, what's the word
in English [foreign word].
The misbehave one, misbehaved one.
>> The spoiled one.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: The
spoiled one, the spoiled one.
[ Foreign Language ]
Don't be, get over here.
Right and you could see all those
[foreign word] and all those notices
and writings, even that newspaper
inspired the younger ones
at that time, like myself so we
all created little newspapers
in our communities.
Kind of modeled in some ways after
[foreign word], with a local news
of the day among the
students in communities.
So all those things are also
part of this amazing moment
with Dolores Huerta, Cesar
Chavez, Filipino, Filipina,
farm workers and leaders.
>> Yeah thank you.
>> Georgette Dorn: Yeah
thank you very much.
>> Taina Caragol: Well thank you
very much for your questions.
I'd like to thank the poets, I
have to say that as a curator
of the show, you know the main
medium of exhibitions relies
on visual material and on text,
on the text that is on the walls.
And I feel that through their
art, Arlene, Juan Felipe
and Diana have really
expanded massively.
What is on the walls in the show?
And I could hear it and I could see
it happening and it was right there
as they, as they read, was
a very very powerful moment
and thank you very much for that.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Thank you Taina [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.